optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking pronounce your thoughts on
question now it soon
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by 99designs 99designs is
a great partner for creating and growing
your business it's a one-stop shop for
all of your graphic design needs whether
that's a logo website business card or
anything else I use 99 designs to get
book cover prototypes for the 4-hour
body which went on to become a number
one New York Times bestseller I also use
them for banner ads illustrations and
other things with 99designs designers
around the world to compete to create
the best design for you you give
feedback and then pick your favorite you
end up happy or you get your money back
it's very simple you can check out a few
of my own designs and those of yours
meaning Tim Ferriss show listeners at 99
designs com forward slash Tim and right
now my listeners you guys will get a
free $99 upgrade on your first design
that's 99 designs com forward slash Tim
check it out this episode is brought to
you by thrive market if you're anything
like me you care a lot about the food
you put into your body in fact I think
it's much more important than exercise
the problem is the good food can be
extremely expensive but it doesn't have
to be thrive market which is one of the
fastest growing startups in the health
space right now is like Costco for
everything healthy an online shop and
Club offering the best brands and
groceries at 25 to 50% off of retail
prices ship nationally for free it's
awesome there are a ton of slow carb
friendly items that I recommend in the
4-hour body you can easily filter
everything by your preferences whether
you're paleo gluten-free vegan raw
non-gmo vegetarian veterinarian whatever
so go to thrive market calm
forward-slash Tim and check it out you
can get a free two month trial and 25%
off your first order when you sign up
for membership if you sign up it's fifty
nine ninety five per year which is only
five dollars a month at the very least
go there and check out the avocado Mayo
they have which is amazing not only that
for every paying member thrive gives a
free membership to a low-income family
veteran or teacher which is awesome and
helps
level the playing field so you can get
ripped while you're doing some good also
never pay full price for healthy food
again check it out thrive market calm
forward-slash Tim to start your free
two-month trial and get 25% off your
first order what you have to lose
nothing go check it out
avocado Mayo it's read thrive market
calm forward-slash tim hand up boys and
girls this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
I'm garbling words late at night
whispering in a hotel room in New York
City outside of my window is a Christmas
tree with white lights on it and all the
children are snug in their beds with
visions of sugarplums dancing in their
heads but I digress this episode is a
special one and if you've enjoyed in
betweenness odes in the past this is not
a long-form interview actually it is
kind of a long-form interview then this
might be your favorite episode ever
might end up really being your top pick
for most actionable information packed
into one interview that I've ever done
and came about in part because I have
many conversations with journalists and
the pain always strikes me when I have a
one to two hour conversation and then it
gets cut down to a single sentence as a
quote in a piece often times a misquote
and then the one to two hours just never
get used and then furthermore I can't
use it if they have a recording and they
have a boss who has a boss who has a
boss it just turns into a huge headache
and it makes me sad so how do you fix
that
well you record it yourself on your side
which doubles as a way to cover your ass
with media and journalists you say well
hey I'll record it on my side via Skype
with ECAM call recorders backup cool and
if they're recording and you're
recording you all agree then you're not
breaking any laws and it sounds good and
fantastic and I actually spoke to Joel
Stein who is one of the funniest writers
I have ever read and I'm not alone in
this there are many many many many
people who would agree with me and you
have to check him out I asked him if I
could use this audio he very graciously
said yes go for it do whatever you want
with it and his site is the Joel Stein
ste I
dot-com and on the Twitter you can check
them out one of my favorite people
follow on Twitter hilarious right up
there with Patton Oswalt is the Joel
Stein so Twitter calm /the Joel Stein
please say hi to him would we cover in
this episode we cover how I choose what
to improve how do I pick the one single
thing to tweak out of infinite options
how you can subtract your way to success
the genius of Ben Franklin why self
improvement doesn't have to mean
self-centered and tactical tips for for
fulfilling that how I say no to
time-consuming lunches coffees and so on
which is massive time suck how I tackle
and others might tackle the bane of
so-called cold introductions God do I
hate those the last few things I've
improved in my life Lyme disease some of
the ways that I was able to surmount
that by making hypotheses a couple of
notes mostly taking a break from
startups is something I say in this that
is now a hundred percent true I am off
completely as of six months ago out of
the game completely I did write a public
piece called why I'm taking a long
startup vacation or how to say no when
it matters most if you just search Tim
Ferriss or Ferriss two hours two S's and
startup vacation I'll pop right up if
you are interested in reading the entire
manifesto which applies to almost every
possible area of life my podcast process
we get into how I thought about
automating and really streamlining my
podcast process and this was recorded in
2015 this is about a hundred episodes
ago so you get to see the early thinking
which hasn't changed that much so that
might be fun for some view tools and
tactics for reversing email overwhelm a
couple of notes on that number one slack
I mentioned that once pops up again this
is 2015 and slack folks this one's on me
hope it makes you a million bucks
okay next time give me some money Thanks
IBM man who eliminated email I mentioned
this I'm not sure if it's IBM man or
Intel woman I'm not sure but I believe
it was someone at IBM if you know the
name please let me know via twitter at
tea Ferriss limit oh this was all
initially recorded for five episodes
that Joel hoped to use to improve
himself each time picking an important
area and you wanted to talk to me first
about how to select those damn areas in
the first place among other things when
we dig into everything and he wanted me
to promise something that I couldn't
deliver so I'm not going to do that but
I came up with a substitute
I implore each and every one of you to
watch or re-watch the movie idiocracy it
might have some relevance for our
current presidential election / process
/ theater debacle could help you out so
check it out
edy ah cracy treated as a documentary
but with some time travel involved and
last but not least please check out Joel
you will be so happy that you did the
Joel Stein comm and on Twitter at the
Joel Stein
so twitter.com forward slash the Joel
Stein and th e Jol ste I N and as I
always say but seldom comply with
without further ado please enjoy my
conversations about 30 minutes with Joel
Stein okay so the idea for this podcast
I'm just doing five episodes is that I'm
going to improve myself in some way in
each podcast like I'm going to become a
better husband and Avenue maybe find a
new job and become more assertive things
like that but we haven't even picked all
five yet so I wanted to turn to you and
first of all how do you get started in
self-improvement well I think
self-improvement is a dicey term in area
because there are a lot of charlatans a
lot of motivational speakers who are
light on daily practical tactics things
like that I would just say that you
should identify your pain points and an
easy way to do that is to sit down with
whatever it might be you could use an
application like Evernote or word or
whatever is comfortable for you or
notepad and do an 80/20 analysis to
identify the 20% of make a list of the
say 20% of activities relationships
people whatever it might be that caused
80% of your negative emotions and
negative outcomes right so really just
go through a brain dump as an exercise
and then you can start to identify the
changes that correlate to removing the
sources of stress and I think that one
of the failures of most self-help
recommendations is that number one they
don't really have a solid grounding in
behavioral change and the the science
and research behind that and secondly
they focus on always adding additional
things and not creating a not to do list
so I think the the subtraction can be
just as valuable as the addition so the
80/20 analysis is a good place to start
I think you know okay one this is this
very small pain point with points is
something larger and I feel like you
deal with this so much more than me
which is like people you know and kind
of like who asked you to lunch and just
become a time sock even though they're
nice and interesting and everything how
do you say no to them when you I always
say I'm busy that day but then they just
pick three more days right then it just
gets punted to pain further down the
line I I have a couple of different
approaches I use and there are many
different coping mechanisms for this
some work better than others
I will I will say either categorically
I'm avoiding certain types of activities
so for instance I'm taking largely a
break from startup investing at the
moment for for a host of reasons that we
can get into if you want but I won't
bore you with it right now and I'm very
highly concentrated in that kind of
asset class so I when I respond to say
an introduction from a venture
capitalist to a CEO which is the hardest
to turn down because you're now going to
offend two people not just one and
requests for lunch related to kind of
categorically that type of activity I
will just respond with you know heads
down on deadlines or on other projects
taking a break you know taking a quote
startup vacation end quote for the next
X period of time and I've noticed that
there are many people who use this busy
people you know in some cases worth
hundreds or hundred
or more who will use this vacation in
quotations for many different things I'm
taking a meeting vacation Forex period
of time to focus on a and B I'm taking a
fill-in-the-blank vacation for expert of
time and that way you're not pushing it
off and basically giving you're not
putting a band-aid solution on it that's
just going to rub off and come back to
you in a month's time and they'll say
hey following up just like you suggested
and then you're going to really paint
yourself into a corner so that's one
approach making sort of public
announcements about policies writing I
mean you're a writer so this works
perfectly for you so I will probably be
putting out something public soon about
for instance cold email introductions
where someone doesn't ask permission to
email you and they introduce you to fill
in the blank type of person who can then
reply and see see all of the co-founders
whatever might be it's a huge problem
but you have the leverage of a platform
and the ability to write so that
actually gives you a very easy out in in
some sense because you can write about
tackling these issues yeah that's I
thought there's a general rule you have
to ask someone's permission before you
introduce them that's like an Adam grant
rule yeah it's a it's a very good rule
but it's violated all the time and it's
it's I think it's particularly rampant
in the early-stage startup investing
world but it's it's it's true in many
many many other places as well but the
the crux of self-improvement I think and
there are differing opinions on this
could be echoed by say Peter Drucker if
the Benjamin theory so what gets
measured gets managed I think that
nebulous goals produce very at best
mediocre returns so you have to for
instance like learning Spanish is not a
great goal because it's not measurable
becoming a better husband in the
abstract a great goal but in the
implementation a terrible objective
because you don't really have it's not
granular enough and you don't have
metrics right so you'd have to decide
how you're going to measure your before
your baseline and how you're going to
assess your progress or you
after and I that's that's something I
feel very strongly about and I'm kind of
militant about that aspect when I when I
try to tweak variables in my own life
which are either you know oftentimes
associated with some type of performance
goal but not always so one of the last
few things you improved in your life so
I can get an idea of what's measurable
sure I had about nine months of my life
removed by Lyme disease I had a very
severe
it's very severe symptoms of Lyme
disease and it was confirmed I
contracted it on Long Island which has
one of the highest despite my dad got
Lyme disease twice even though yeah it's
right near you actually lives in quad
yeah it's it's a it can be very
debilitating disease with a lot of
neurological symptoms and joint pain and
so on so I started experimenting with
various diets based on hypotheses that I
had right so you have to start with any
scientific experiment which is what I
would view what you're doing is you have
a hypothesis so you know doing X will
make me a better husband or in my case I
thought potentially Lyme is similar to
say like herpes simplex that it can lay
dormant and then neurotoxins I don't
know anything about herpes whatsoever
yeah well fur is really clear yeah I
know all you need to all you need to
know is that people talk about chronic
Lyme as a recurring condition right so
there are a couple of hypotheses one is
that there could be common triggers like
artificial certain artificial sweeteners
that I should remove and then I could
assess sort of the severity of symptoms
as they correlate or don't correlate to
that the other thing is and I won't go
too deep here but is I have a theory
right hypothesis that Lyme may interfere
with carbohydrate metabolism in some way
so I tested the ketogenic diet which is
like the Atkins diet and had a device
called the precision extra which is
intended for diabetics but it allows me
to measure my ketone levels in a
millimolar concentration and
behold my cognitive symptoms and
everything else
effectively vanished when I got to a
certain ketone level now is that causal
is it just correlative are there other
variables sure but it's a very promising
start so that's that would be one way
that I might measure it you could do
this in a in a less technical way where
you have you either assess or someone
else assesses you on a zero to ten point
scale so for instance I have a friend
he's in a older jet is in 60s he has a
is a very good marriage that's very good
relationship with his wife or he could
really shoot his kids every quarter his
wife grades him on a ten-point scale in
four categories father husband provider
and lover and what's what's what was so
fascinating and I thought smart about
how they did this is that he doesn't
have to maintain a certain ranking in
each category he has to maintain a
certain total so let's just say for the
sake of argument that it's a thirty
point scale well he might be traveling a
lot for business and not spending a lot
of time on the phone or otherwise
communicating why for a given quarter so
you might have a very high provider
score say eight nine ten a very low
husband score and probably a low lover
score but he could make up for that by
being a good father right really
focusing on the father category and that
would ultimately give him the total
number of points necessary to check the
I am being sort of a a a good version of
myself for my wife and my family so
that's that's a simple non-technical way
to approach something like that for
instance
yeah sounds like a good way they just
have an excuse to buy your wife's love
well it's also I think underscores
something else which is you shouldn't
take advice from anyone who has not been
able to implement the same advice
successfully for themselves and in this
case I was not talking to someone who
had been married for a year I was
talking to someone who had been married
for 20-plus years right
and runs it works yeah at least in and
again that that isn't necessarily the
only contributing factor but he felt
very strongly that it was and all that
means is you have a hypothesis worth
disproving right it gives you something
to test that's it so one thing I've
thought about is far because I've done
things like I'm in really good shape
down as I did a story for GQ where they
had me get in really good shape I've
done things where I've kind of changed
myself I always wonder what
self-improvement as I improve myself and
really focus on myself is am I actually
just doing more damage by making me a
bad person as I'm not focusing on other
people you know my family I think it
depends exactly or entirely I should say
on what you're focusing on and I don't
think improving oneself and improving
either or both your interactions with
other people or the world at large are
mutually exclusive right so I think it's
it might be a false dichotomy and so
much as if you look at say Ben Franklin
and his 13 virtues you had humility
sincerity these are things that affect
other people and ostensibly would
improve his ability to interact with the
world around him and I think that it
depends entirely on the objectives that
you choose whether you're focusing on
self-improvement or not I think that
your focus determines how selfish
self-interested or otherwise you are so
I think that it can cut both ways and it
just it depends a lot on what targets
you choose but you have you found that
people who follow your advice sometimes
become self oriented in the bad way ah
that's a good question I I would imagine
that is the case I would imagine it has
to be the case you know if I have
whatever it might be you know 2 million
people or so per month coming to the
blog as unique visitors I would imagine
that you have all sorts of interesting
patterns in the data including people
who end up focusing on themselves to the
exclusion of others now I would
emphasize or I would propose that it's
possible I'm not saying this is
altogether the case but it's possible
just in the way
that it's easier for people to focus on
say improving the world and
philanthropic work like Bill Gates for
instance after they have amassed a
certain amount of capital and satisfied
a the majority of rungs on Maslow's
hierarchy of needs I think it's possible
that to be as selfless as possible it to
be as selfless as you are capable of you
might focus very selfishly on yourself
for a period of time coming back to what
you asked earlier about saying no to
people right so saying no to a thousand
things so that you can focus on the one
most important highly-leveraged
project in your life may in the long
term allow you to do the greatest good
so I think it's a calculus you have to
run but is it possible that someone
could be a selfish bastard by focusing
on you know reading a thousand self-help
books and never lending a helping hand
to other people sure I'm sure those
people exist and what are the things
people most want to improve a pod I mean
I have my guesses but what does it turn
out to be that stuff they can actually
measure I think that you know the modern
the the fears of modern men and women
can kind of be boiled down to getting
fat and getting too many email uh I
think that those are those are two that
crop up continually I mean they're met
there are many fears fears of death and
so on so you have the the Peter Till's
and others here in Silicon Valley trying
to crack the code with immortality but
if we really want to focus on the daily
the daily grind and the basics I think
that fat having too much fat eating too
much fat whatever might be and email
overwhelm or the general state of kind
of digital overwhelm or two things that
most people seem preoccupied with and
fortunately they're both they both
provide a lot of different metrics you
could potentially use I thought you were
going to mention in addition to fat
money and sex I'm sure people worry
about those things and they're also both
measurable you know I mean you could you
could say you could compare
our tinder to other dating profiles you
could you could use data to say take
five or six profile photos and put them
up on OkCupid using a service they offer
called my best face which allows people
to vote on your photos so you determine
which get the highest click-through
rates and these can all be broken down
to measurables and so i'm my measure
will be i think cutting down on my time
spent on emails and stuff it would be
great what so the measurable is what
they're well the measurable could be the
number of email answered right so so
aiming to answer fewer email total which
i think is a good is a is a is a good
metric simply because if you if you
listen to people like say Robert Scoble
who's a technologist his can hypothesis
which it's not really hypothesis based
on his experience is that forever email
he sends out he gets I think 1.75 on
average in in return right so you can
the goal should not be to just do more
things right because it's it's possible
to be very efficient ie
do things quickly but focus on things
that are unimportant so my goal is
always to try to in this case for
instance focus on being effective which
is doing the right things and in the
case of email is having say an
auto-response a piece of public writing
that allow you to safely ignore 70 or 80
percent of your email as opposed to
simply responding to those emails in a
faster fashion now the there the metrics
you should you can come up with a
laundry list and then pick one or two
that are kind of your key metrics and
this goes for behaviors as well and what
I mean by that is you want to try to
pick the variables in your life that
have a cascading positive effect so for
instance if your goal is to drink less
coffee you should ask yourself well why
do you drink so much coffee well it's
because I wake up and I feel tired well
why do you wake up and you feel tired
it's because I go to bed really late
well why do you go to bed really late
because I bitterly go out three or four
nights a week and have drinks with
friends okay why do you go out of town
for drinks with friends three or four
nights per week if it makes you feel so
shitty because I have a tough time
saying no to their invitations okay we
can kind of track back to an initial
snowball that leads to these other
things so if you just try to cut back on
your coffee it won't work unless you
address kind of the the earlier
cascading effects and I think that's
true with with variables right it's it's
possible to improve your speed ranking
in answering email but if that's just
leading to you answering more trivial
email as opposed to the critical few it
you're playing the wrong game but I mean
for email for instance tool that I think
is is very easy to implement if you're
using Gmail is boomerang which allows
you to schedule emails to be set in the
future it allows you to automate
follow-up so that if someone doesn't
reply it brings it to your top to the
top you very inbox it removes a lot of
the cognitive load of email processing
and those would be a few examples and I
mean there many more the one one of the
few things ever fixed about myself was
being late which I fixed in my late 20s
and basically I do all the work you just
described which was figuring out oh I'm
really soft conscious if I get somewhere
early and I don't know what to do
physically with myself it was before you
could play with your cell phone how to
like train myself to go in public and
stand there and not feel self-conscious
and then I was able not to be late
anymore right yeah so I think what
you're saying about email is the same
thing like I am afraid of confrontation
and being thought of as a jerk so I'm
afraid not to respond we have to fix
that yeah exactly
ah being afraid of confrontation well
you know I mean you could and we don't
have to necessarily go into a
psychoanalysis session now but I mean
you could even you could go back that
may not be the end of the story or the
beginning of the story right I mean you
could go back even further and say like
why am i afraid of people thinking it
with me or thinking of me as rude and uh
it would be very helpful I know I'm
digressing very briefly here I will sit
down in the morning after I meditate for
20 minutes which i think is a huge
kind of force multiplier for a lot of
these behaviors and sit down in Journal
for five minutes and basically try to
take all of my anxieties whatever those
might be and put them on paper and that
will oftentimes sort of empower you to
make decisions when you see how
groundless most of them are but how do
you it it can take that it can take many
forms right I mean you could you it
takes number one there's like the fact
gathering mission right so is this
assumption actually based in fact right
so can you find examples where that's
the case and in my in my particular
instance with the startup the startup
world and VC's you know venture
capitalists are introducing beta
founders without asking me first and
then those founders say hey great to
meet you Tim you know looping in my five
co-founders whatever the hell it would
turn into a mess and then I looked at my
most successful deals and you could look
at the most important pivotal projects
in your life just say pieces of writing
whatever it might be that led to
positive inflection points in your life
were any of those the direct response to
saying yes to invitations you otherwise
wanted to turn down right and in my case
I realized none of my best startups if I
look at again 80/20 analysis what are
the 20% of the deals I've invested in
that it produced 80 percent or more of
my returns none of those deals came from
code email introductions from VCS not a
single one so I think I think that
decreasing anxiety and tackling some of
these 30 or psychological issues starts
with testing assumptions and
fact-finding Wow oh this is all
incredibly helpful I'm gonna ask my
producer Sarah hi Shara hi anything else
we should ask him um yeah well this is a
very specific question but um I know
that there was a BuzzFeed writer who
recently got rid of his email altogether
yep and I mean like what do you think of
that because we have so many different
forms of communication now why just you
know maybe we should just be eliminating
some of them and that could reduce some
of Joel's potential anxiety and the true
people who want to get in touch with him
get in touch
with them I agree with that I agree that
email is is a tool that has been
misappropriated for a lot of tasks for
which it was not initially designed and
there are many people who have gone off
I shouldn't say many but more than a
handful of people there's another gent
from IBM who has banished email from his
toolkit and has done so for several
years there are there are many different
tools in the toolkit right so I think
that some of the options worth examining
could be number one some type of project
management software whether that's asana
Basecamp Trello for instance for
assigning tasks with deadlines so that
email does not become a follow up system
is very helpful identifying a nut sound
like beating a dead horse but doing it
80/20 analysis of your Inbox
right so who are say the top five who
are the five to ten people who
communicate with you most via email and
trying to identify asking yourself what
other tools could do this job better
than email and I think you'd find that
project management software very helpful
but on top of that you could look at say
within any given organization using a
tool like slack slack has become
extremely popular in fast-growing
startups you might be hiring you know
ten fifty a hundred people over the over
the course of several months it becomes
more and more important as you scale and
I think that if for instance you're
trying to I'm just using a hypothetical
but in my case rather than say training
multiple people to help me moderate
comments on the blog I could use a tool
like ScreenFlow which allows you to
record your screen and your voice while
you're moderating comments I take that
video I put it into Dropbox and I never
have to teach that skill again now I
have a link that I can send to anyone I
need to train to do that I never have to
Blayne it again so for any repetitive
task if you're thinking about this like
an engineer engineers abhor repetitive
task so that's why they write scripts
and get good at programming and so on if
you start thinking about your life in
that way and sort of the for a
repetitive task if you only could do
this once and never again what system
would you have to put in place you can
cultivate this kind of tool agnostic
problem-solving mindset and wait just
because I'm gonna go do this as soon as
we hang up the 80/20 analysis is I
figure out what the twenty what the
things are that uh
20% of my things that are using up 80%
of my time or causing me 80% of my
opinion that would be one implementation
and it doesn't have to be the 80/20 is a
guideline right so it could be that one
percent of the people the email you
produce ninety nine or more or a hundred
percent of your email using it to find
my pain points yeah using it to find
both the good and the bad so for
instance if you're running a company or
let's just say from an income standpoint
because you mentioned money so it's like
what are what are the 20% of the
projects that you work on that produce
80% or more of your income this will
allow you to separate the trivial many
from the critical few if you're trying
to kind of replicate your successes
while avoiding the noise as much as
possible I find it helpful for people
because they people seek out self-help
typically not because everything is
working great and they just want to make
it perfect it's because they have pain
points or sources of stress that are
causing them some type of overwhelm or
self-doubt in that case I find it
helpful to start with you know what are
the 20% of activities in my life that
are causing 80% of the stress or
negative emotions insomnia etc what are
the who are the 20% of the people I
spend time with who are producing 80% of
the headache the anxiety the anger the
insomnia et cetera and that gives you a
not to do list around which you can
build routines and habits that you can
test to assess how those feelings go up
or down for instance I beside besides
the ketones what are you working on
right
on yourself let's see if it's asthma
ketones I'm working on podcast process
so production process post-production
process and you know the first thing
that I'll do is I put together Google
Doc and we have maybe a tour when at ten
to twelve steps discrete steps that I'm
currently using to take a podcast from
kind of planning stage to booking a
guest to recording to post-production
first thing I'll do is try to eliminate
as many steps as possible
so rather than just asking how do I do
all these things faster like which of
these steps are redundant unnecessary or
just unimportant I think they're really
important but they're not actually that
important such as putting up a blog post
like how important is it to put up a
corresponding blog post how mend the way
you assess important is how is that
affecting my-my-my metric and my metric
is let's just say a number of downloads
or listens per episode right then so
let's say I take that twelve steps and I
break it I cut it down to eight I decide
that and I'm in the middle of doing this
right now so with someone else trying to
cut down 12 to 8 or 7 or whatever it is
at that point then I ask you know what
can I add here some kind of defining
things then I'm asking automating what
can I use technology to automate here so
for instance like as soon as I put up a
blog post if I decide to do that that
could I could use a program like if this
then that which i think is just IFTTT or
i ftt to automatically put a promotion
up on Twitter and Facebook so I don't
have to think about it I don't have to
delegate it okay so it's kind of
definition elimination removing as many
steps as possible automation choosing
tech to automate things so that people
aren't involved and then the last is the
sort of delegation piece so if at that
point what is remaining and what of
those can I delegate so if I if I need
artwork for instance for a thumbnail for
each podcast which I don't but let's say
I did I could go to like a 99designs or
a Fiverr or one of these sites and have
someone else manage that process for me
I feel like there are
six or seven apps you haven't even
mentioned yet there are a UPS I don't
actually have that many apps on my phone
I think that it's technology is a
technology as a wonderful tool and a
terrible master and a lot of people
confuse amassing tools or motion with
progress and that's it's a very
seductive easy path to take because
we're constantly sold the the hype of
downloading this one new app and it will
change your life down load this other
new app and it will streamline a B or C
and I think that most people are
drowning in a glut of tools and the
reason for that is that they don't have
any precise goals they don't have
precise goals and measurable tools I one
more question Tim yeah so one thing so
one thing with this podcast that we've
been thinking about is that we have
these bigger ideas and one of the topics
that we want to tackle too is
assertiveness so would we for using
assertiveness as an example we would do
the 80/20 for assertiveness and see what
the pain points truly are for Churchill
in what is making him more passive and
assertive uh 80/20 well assertiveness is
I to be honest I would have to think on
that I don't want to give you a
knee-jerk response that isn't helpful
but the the assertiveness I would start
with Joel sitting down and journaling
and kind of going backwards and asking
three or four and wise about why he has
trouble being assertive right so if it's
I am straight he could do an 80/20
analysis on his sources of stress this
is a general broad 8020 of as I
described the sources of stress I would
start there because maybe being
assertive or assertiveness is not the
problem you need to fix right I will
take your word at for it but it's let's
start with just 8020 to identify the 20%
of activities people etc that are
causing 80% of the negative emotions
that you wants to avoid from there then
you could sit down and journal meaning
just kind of free him
stream-of-consciousness right you know
why trying to answer the question like
why do I feel I am not assertive enough
and just right for five to ten minutes
and whenever he thinks he's reached a
conclusion ask why right so if it's I
don't answer you know I answered more
email than I should I feel I feel
compelled to answer more email than I
should
why answer that well it's because I feel
ABCD right well why do you feel those
things because this this this and at the
end of it looking at that and asking you
know which of these assumptions have not
been tested that's that's where I would
start and I don't want to make it seem
like a assertiveness is a very big broad
word and I get anxious when people are
trying to fix anything that is very
broad I think you got it you have to get
very specific but those the a20 analysis
the journaling and then I would ask okay
what would the how could I test these
assumptions right how could I test these
assumptions and one of them might be you
know I need to respond as quickly as
possible or I'll lose the respective mic
my co-workers and that will end you know
why do you care about that well because
it'll have this effect you could just
test that and I'm not saying this is
what you do right because certain jobs
are suited to this and some are not but
you could test an autoresponder and to
give you an example this is one of
dozens of potential tools but let's just
say that's how you test the assumption I
had this radio station manager come up
to me at South by Southwest at one point
he said you know I'd love to try
non-responder but there's no way I could
do it because my boss my boss would
probably fire me I mean I need to be
responsive at all times especially
during the conference and I said well
that's that may or may not be true but
it's an assumption you can test so why
don't you set up an autoresponder that
you can turn off literally with the
click of a button if your boss gets
upset and no I think you're you're under
estimating your value during a busy
conference he's not going to hire you an
IRA fire you and hire someone new in the
middle of the busiest season it's just
it would be a stupid managerial decision
so he put up a risky putting
autoresponder and he sent me a follow-up
and he said I thought you'd love the
response and
and his boss wrote to him ins who was
managing multiple stations and said love
this approach I which I wish more of the
managers would use this and cc'd all the
other managers because this boss was
getting C seeded on every bit of minutia
and his problem was ten times worse than
those other managers and so it his
assumption was completely unfounded in
fact the way his boss felt it was
exactly the opposite so that's a lot but
I'm just saying 80/20 analysis as I
described journaling why this why that
why why why going back identifying
assumptions that you haven't tested
determining how you can test them and I
can't I can't spoon feed you the answers
to that if to just sit down do some hard
thinking and then determining the
metrics the numbers that you could
assign or or use as a measurement for
testing those assumptions and then to
that point you can you can form the
hypothesis if I do this then desirable
outcome X right at that point then
you're moving into behavioral change but
before you can before you change
something you want to assess your
current got a current state of matters
and those final question is after
talking to me on the right now what do
you think my likelihood of success is
impossible to answer if you follow the
prescription that I have put out and
focus on measurable measurable
objectives changing as few variables as
possible don't try to change ten
behaviors at once and rigging the game
and that way so that it is possible to
win I and you have a timeline that is
has been rationally thought through I
think I think the likelihood that
success could be very high now I will
tell you I understand this piece have to
be entertaining and I'm not sure if it
would be entertaining if your path to
success were very clear so I'm
so to that extent that's an unknown in
my head but you're mean you're a smart
guy you've changed behaviors before I
think that there's there's a very high
chance of success if you kind of follow
a framework that has worked for
thousands tens of thousands probably
millions of people because a lot of
these principles go back hundreds or
even thousands of years these are not
new principles well I can't thank you
enough I didn't mean to take this much
your time we took 45 Tim Ferriss minutes
which you see that's that's four human
hours yes yeah gotta measure it measure
it in dog years but any any friend of
Neal's is a friend of mine and I enjoy
your work so I'm happy to happy to chat
oh definitely put that in the podcast
and uh I will call you when this whole
thing's over just to ask some wrap-up
questions sure thing and ping me any
time thank you so much Tim of course
guys take it easy all right
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by thrive
market if you're anything like me you
care a lot about the food you put into
your body in fact I think it's much more
important than exercise the problem is
the good food can be extremely expensive
but it doesn't have to be thrive market
which is one of the fastest growing
startups in the health space right now
is like Costco for everything healthy an
online shopping club offering the best
brands and groceries at 25 to 50% off of
retail prices shift nationally for free
it's awesome there are a ton of slow
carb friendly items that I recommend in
the 4-hour body you can easily filter
everything by your preferences whether
you're paleo gluten-free vegan raw
non-gmo vegetarian veterinarian whatever
so go to thrive market calm /cam and
check it out you can get a free 2 month
trial and 25% off your first order when
you sign up for membership if you sign
up it's fifty nine ninety five per year
which is only $5 a month at the very
least go there and check out the avocado
Mayo they have which is amazing not only
that for repaying member thrive gives a
free membership to a low-income family
veteran or teacher which is awesome and
helps level the playing field so you can
get ripped while you're doing some good
also never pay full price for healthy
food again check it out thrive
market.com forward slash Tim to start
your free to up trial and get 25% off
your first order wouldn't lose nothing
go check it out
avocado Mayo it's read thrive market
calm forward slash 10
this episode is brought to you by
99designs 99designs is a great partner
for creating and growing your business
it's a one-stop shop for all of your
graphic design needs whether that's a
logo website business card or anything
else I use 99 designs to get book cover
prototypes for the 4-hour body which
went on to become a number one New York
Times best seller they also use them for
banner ads illustrations and other
things with 99designs designers around
the world to compete to create the best
design for you you give feedback and
then pick your favorite you end up happy
or you get your money back it's very
simple you can check out a few of my own
designs and those of yours meaning Tim
Ferriss show listeners at 99 designs com
forward slash Tim and right now my
listeners you guys will get a free $99
upgrade on your first design that's 99
designs com forward slash Tim check it
out and until next time thank you for
listening